un président curret qui résonne
exclusivement en rapport de sens
il considère l'europe comme un
adversaire qu'il a toujours réussi à
faire plier en pariant qu'il n'y aura
jamais d escalade avec des alliés il
continue à affirmer ou lire diplomatico
militaire indépendant par rapport à ses
alliés de l'otan tout en se déclarant un
membre totalement fiable de cette
organisation
la négociation sera difficile avec un
interlocuteur qui n'hésite pas à se
mettre sur la ligne rouge pour forcer le
destin
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 black sun araw
ni la gravité de la pandémie il a été
élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon et disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie tout
[Musique]
la réforme du parquet repoussée eric
dupond moretti était à l'épreuve du
sénat cet après midi annonce principal
la révision constitutionnelle ne se fera
pas tout de suite le nouveau ministre de
la justice continue de faire face aux
parlementaires à la suite de sa
nomination au gouvernement
mike pompéo en visite au danemark ce
mercredi un an après l'imbroglio sur
l'offre de rachat par donald trump du
groenland
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
souhaite renforcer la coopération dans
l'arctique
il a insisté sur la nouvelle compétition
à l'oeuvre sur le territoire allusion
aux intentions de la chine sur cette
région
[Musique]
visite diplomatique en russie également
le ministre algérien des affaires
étrangères a rencontré son homologue
sergueï lavrov objectif renforcer les
liens bilatéraux entre moscou et alger
au centre des discussions partenariat
économique entre les deux pays mais
également les dossiers libyen et syrien
[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de passer
cette soirée en votre compagnie
bienvenue sur rt france pour une
nouvelle demi heure d'information
eric dupond-moretti auditionné au sénat
ce mercredi le garde des sceaux a
répondu aux questions des parlementaires
devant la commission des lois
entretien demandé par les sénateurs à la
suite de sa nomination au gouvernement
on fait le point avec notre reporter 4
s'applique le nouveau ministre de la
justice a été entendu par la commission
des lois
il a rappelé son attachement à la
présomption d'innocence est une justice
rendue au plus près des gens il souhaite
que les délits les incivilités soient
jugés rapidement notamment pour le cas
des mineurs il a rappelé son attachement
également à la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
et puis il a été interrogé par les
sénateurs sur la transparence de la
justice
aura-t-il des remontées d'informations
dans le cas d'affaires par exemple qu'il
a pu plaider ou concernant des affaires
personnelles et bien selon lui il faut
qu'il soit tenu au courant des affaires
et qui intéresse l'état mais dans le cas
de gérald darmanin at il expliqué il
n'avait pas eu récemment de remontée
d'informations je vous propose de
l'écouter à ce sujet jewil notamment et
les adverbes ne sont pas inutiles
monsieur président j'estime que le garde
des sceaux peut recevoir des
informations sur des affaires qui
concernent le fonctionnement de l'état
eh bien je vais vous dire je n'ai à à ce
stade
voyez-vous reçu strictement aucune
information sur la situation de monsieur
darmanin je sais une chose et vous la
partagerez avec moi c'est qu'il est
présumé innocent nous sommes tous
d'accord là dessus je n'ai madame reçu
strictement aucune information sur cette
situation
au sujet de l'indépendance de la justice
eric dupond moretti a laissé entendre
que le congrès allait prochainement être
convoqués pour adopter la réforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
et puis il a également évoqué le
désengorgement des prisons qu'ils
souhaitent car les conditions
pénitentiaires sont mauvaises en france
à ce sujet je vous propose d'écouter la
sénatrice elle
esther benbassa ou sortir de l'audition
il n'a pas répondu à deux questions
l'une c'était sur les conditions de
détention dans les prisons surpeuplées
et
la deuxième c'était sur l'encombrement
des tribunaux
il a répondu que pour les prisons sûres
il a parlé des fameux trois volets voilà
il a parlé de l'insertion également il a
aussi dit que il ya des la détention
provisoire elle dure trop longtemps et
ça bien sûr ça en comble les prisons
qu'il faut raccourcir les délais en
conclusion eric dupond moretti a répété
qu'il n'était ni laxiste ni ultra
répressif mais il compte bien changer le
regard que portent les français sur la
justice en tout cas il n'a que six ans
jour pour faire changer les choses
il a d'ores et déjà confié lors de cette
audition qu'il ne pourrait pas mener à
bien une partie des réformes auxquelles
il rêvait faute de temps alors que la
barre des 15 millions de cas était à
dépasser dans le monde le carnaval est
inquiète toujours les français et
notamment une éventuelle deuxième vague
épidémique 66% des personnes interrogées
disent redouter un deuxième épisode
épidémique selon un sondage au doxa pour
fiducial dévoilés ce matin par le figaro
une préoccupation qui arrive en tête
devant la délinquance et le terrorisme
le port du masque en première ligne pour
lutter contre le virus obligatoire
depuis lundi emmanuel maps on estime que
le contribuable n'a pas vocation à payer
des masques gratuitement pour tous un
conseil de défense menée par le chef de
l'état assure la reprise de l'épidémie
aura lieu ce vendredi afin d'étudier à
de nouvelles mesures annonce à du porte
parole du gouvernement et envoyait la
balle a également évoqué des pistes pour
une distribution gratuite des masques
aux plus précaires
le président de la république a rappelé
notre mobilisation pour que tous les
français puissent disposer d'un masque
ce qui nous a amenés dans un premier
temps à augmenter les capacités de
production en france et les importations
de masques notamment de masse grand
public pour que tous les français
puissent se procurer un masque et puis à
la question des personnes qui n'ont pas
financièrement les moyens de s'acheter
un masque sur ce point des débuts de la
crise je rappelle que nous avions mis à
disposition à chaque semaine 2 5
millions de masques par semaine pour
être distribués notamment via les
centres communaux d'action sociale aux
personnes très cardan
trop pays et hier le ministre des
solidarités de la santé a indiqué que
nous allions reprendre cette
distribution
nous sommes actuellement en train de
finaliser plusieurs pistes notamment la
piste d'envois postaux à des
bénéficiaires ciblés particulièrement
pour jean philippe tanguy porte parole
debout la france le gouvernement est
dépassée en réalisation de sa réponse
sanitaire à la crise surtout en région
ile de france
ah mais c'est toujours le même problème
c'est que le gouvernement ne s'est pas
organiser une réponse sanitaire et
logistique à la crise
comme par hasard c'est l'île de france
qui ne veut plus à déborder
le gouvernement n'a toujours pas compris
que l'île de france de par la densité de
population de par le fait que c'est une
zone à la fois touristique endzone
d'affaires il ya beaucoup de circulation
beaucoup de brassage la population doit
avoir des capacités de test supérieur à
des territoires qui sont plus isolés et
de fait tant mieux pour eux plus
protégés donc c'est toujours le même
problème ce gouvernement est incapable
d'organiser les choses et en plus ne
tire pas les leçons de d'autres pays qui
réussissent mieux comme l'allemagne à
nos portes
c'est toujours un problème de
désorganisation et en plus il raconte
n'importe quoi c'est que il n'assume ils
mentent aux français avant il faut dire
la vérité il monte aux français car ils
sont incapables de produire des
résultats et une fois que c'est possible
d'autres pays arrive nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère show via
les policiers impliqués dans
l'interpellation de l'homme de 42 ans
sont accusés de mensonge c'est ce
qu'affirme en tout cas nos confrères de
mediapart et de libération s'appuyant
sur l' enquête de l'igpn
il indique que ce document mettait en
relief des contradictions entre les
déclarations des policiers et le déroulé
des faits estelle charge des
contradictions selon nos confrères de
mediapart et libération c'est ce que
pointerait l'igpn dans son enquête sur
les circonstances de la mort de cédric
joue via des contradictions entre le
récit des policiers mis en cause et des
vidéos de l'interpellation sur lesquels
la police des polices s'est penché sur
la technique d'interpellations les
éléments demeurent floues michael p
le chef de bord l'un des policiers
présents lors de l'interpellation de
cédric joue via a expliqué aux
enquêteurs de l'egypte
n avoir procédé à un simple maintien de
la tête de l'homme et n'avoir exercé
aucune pression sur son cou une version
confirmée par arnaud b un autre agent
présent lors de l'interpellation qui
affirme ne pas se souvenir d'avoir vu
son collègue faire de pression
selon libération cette version n'aurait
pas convaincu l'igpn laprise dont nous
parlons semble plus s'apparenter à une
prise de lutte au sol
destiné à obtenir la reddition de
l'adversaire qu'à une technique
professionnelle de maîtrise au sol
destinée à accélérer et sécuriser à
menottage une fois au sol
cédric joue via s'est retrouvé allongé
sur le ventre évoquant très rapidement
sa détresse respiratoire une détresse
que les policiers mis en cause ont
toujours nié avoir perçu j'étouffe c'est
pourtant ce que dit cédric joue via à
sept reprises dans une vidéo enregistrée
par son téléphone portable
confronté par l'igpn à cet
enregistrement le chef de bord se
justifie à aucun moment je n'ai entendu
ce qu'il dit là je suis choquée si
j'avais entendu ça on aurait tout
arrêter immédiatement l'un de ses
collègues explique quant à lui ne pas
avoir décelé la teneur des propos
notamment à cause des bruits de la
circulation environnante
autre question soulevée par l'igpn le
temps de réaction de l'équipe
lorsqu'elle constate le malaise du
livreur la police des polices toujours
selon nos confrères de libération et de
mediapart fait étage site d'une période
de flottement relativement longue
lorsqu'il constate le malaise du livreur
les gardiens de la paix met une minute
58 secondes environ pour commencer à lui
enlever les menottes et près de trois
minutes
deux minutes et 56 secondes précisément
pour lui administrer un massage
cardiaque
pourtant les policiers avait
initialement déclaré que leur réaction
face au malaise du livreur avait été
très rapide
autre problème le compte rendu réalisé
par un policier de la bac dont
l'équipage est arrivé en renfort après
l'interpellation selon libération et
mediapart
l'agent qui est aussi le conjoint d'une
policière présente lors de l'arrestation
de cédric joue via aurait donné une
fausse version de l'interpellation pour
mettre hors de cause ses collègues une
fausse version que dénoncerait le
rapport de l'igpn un compte rendu de
l'intervention inexactes pour ce qui
concernait les techniques de maîtrise
engagé
avait été fait auprès de la salle de
commandement pour le moment trois des
quatre policiers impliqués dans
l'interpellation ont été mises en examen
pour homicide involontaire
le quatrième fonctionnaires une
policière a elle été placé sous le
statut de témoin assisté
contacté par mediapart la famille de
cédric chouïa souhaite que les faits
soient requalifiés en homicide
volontaire et en direct avec nous pour
en parler sur arte france christian show
via le père de s séverine souvient
bonsoir merci est d'être avec nous sur
rt france alors cette enquête de l'igpn
on vient de le voir remet en cause les
témoignages des policiers le jour de
l'arrestation
est ce que c'est une surprise pour vous
enfin oui et non parce que depuis depuis
le début ont depuis le début on savait
qu'il y avait un tissu de mensonges
il y avait des témoins il y avait il y
avait des enregistrements et et tout
s'avérait contre les mensonges que que
comment les policiers de données et il y
avait aussi la préfecture enfin tout le
monde tout le monde a menti du début
jusqu'à la fin du moment où j'ai appelé
à 10h30
et puis que ma belle fille a été au
commissariat on n'a pas pu avoir de
nouvelles avant 16 heures parce que il
est en train de préparer une version
tous ensemble avec le le commandent le
policier de la bac est venu qui était
pas sur les faits quand ça s'est passé
et qui a lui orchestré qui a orchestré
toute là là comment le manège de ce
qu'il fallait raconter et après ils ont
tous suivi ses conseils et je pense que
lui fait partie du groupe étant donné
que c'est le conjoint de la policière
qui est pour moi aussi coupables que
pascal a fait qu'un tissu de mensonges
elle a essayé de casser le téléphone de
cédric pour effacer les preuves qu'il
pouvait y avoir dessus donc pour moi
c'est les quatre les quatre puisque lui
c'est tous des menteurs ils ont tous
essayé de camoufler 1 meur et pour moi
je depuis le début je dis que ça meurt
on a tué mon fils et on l'a tué à un
moment donné je pense que si un messie
un homicide volontaire et non un
volontaire pour moi c'est un homicide
volontaire il a été jusqu'au bout
la preuve c'est qu'il s'y est repris à
deux fois c'est bien écrit c'est bien
vue par l'igpn
je remercie l'igpn du travail qu'ils ont
fait et les juges surtout les juges le
travail qu'ils font re est colossal donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de discussion
trois policiers ont été mis en examen
pour homicide involontaire est ce que
vous pensez que ces nouveaux éléments
vont pouvoir requalifier l'anc est en
cours on espère on espère vivement avec
avec toute la famille et puis les
avocats on espère que ça va être
qualifié on espère que monsieur le
ministre
aujourd'hui va reprendre les choses en
main et qui va tenir l'engagement qui
avait tenu castaner le ministre castaner
à l'époque
donc c'est le ministère on va dire si
l'homme n'est plus là il ya au moins le
ministère qui avait plein engagement en
son nom et donc il doit à tout prix
reprendre des mains et les mettre en
mise à pied tous les quatre tous les
quatre et moi je poussera le bouchon à
dire tous les 5 parce que
on est venu il ya le policier de la bac
lui il est venu pour camoufler et puis
pour agrandir le mensonge sur lequel ils
savaient plus comment faire il sait pas
comment faire
il a débarqué on sait pas comment enfin
sur un appel sur un appel de commandes
de sa concubine qui est qui a crié au
secours venez vite on est dans le pétrin
c'est un truc ça du salut est un truc
comme ça et du coup pas aujourd'hui ce
qui ce qu'ils ont oublié ce qu'il y
avait des films y avait des caméras il y
avait des témoins et aujourd'hui on peut
pas revenir là dessus
là c'est pas c'est pas une affaire où il
n'y a pas de preuves ya pas de témoins
il n'y a rien il ya des témoins
il ya des vidéos il ya des
enregistrements tout démontre que c'est
un meurtre
voilà ça je le dis au nom de la famille
au nom de ses cinq enfants qui pleurent
toujours au nom de sa femme nom de sa
mère sa soeur
aujourd'hui on est une famille qui
anéantit assure un tissu de mensonges
et moi je vous dis on se battra jusqu'au
bout parce qu'il n'est pas question
qu'on laisse ça quand on voit toutes les
preuves qui sait qu'ils sont accablantes
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'allemand le préfet
qu'avec kaka qui a été dans le tissu de
mensonges qui a couvert tout ça et
aujourd'hui on se pose la question
est-ce qu'il va rester pas restée moi je
vous le dit c'est des menteurs tous à la
plus grande à la plus grande hauteur du
gouvernement on en a la preuve
aujourd'hui on apprend également que ces
témoignages ont été approuvés par la
hiérarchie
ces policiers on imagine non seulement
un sentiment d'injustice pour vous mais
aussi de la colère est ce que vous
pensez que la mort de votre fils va
faire évoluer les choses en france sur
les violences policières
on espère déjà que le plaquage ventrale
va va être interdite on espère que la
clé d'étranglement va être interdite
pour des contrôles banal il n'y a aucune
raison qu'on en prêt qu'on en place et
on peut convoquer les gens et leur
mettre des amendes
et puis on peut leur mettre des des
peines de sursis en fonction de la laddh
et des circonstances
mais on n'est pas obligé de tuer les
gens pour un contrôle le pour une plaque
salle où n'importe quoi et puis parce
que et puisque parce que cédric a été et
rogner kylesa taquinait avec de l'ironie
et un autre qui accueille la sortie des
grossièretés il est assez vrai ap les
clowns ont dit pas un politicien clowns
ont dit pas on n'est pas respectueux
mais dans l'ironie est ce que vous
croyez que ça mérite la mort moi je
demande aux journalistes lui demandent à
la france entière
est ce que vous croyez que ça mérite
je suis un père de cinq enfants qui est
un travailleur qui se lève le matin et
qui va au boulot
est ce que vous croyez que ça mérite ça
et on sent beaucoup d'émotion à travers
un long mano effectivement effectivement
ça ne mérite pas la mort c'est ce que
vous nous dites on dirait que sur la
terre france ce soir
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
attendez désormais qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait pour que ça change en tout cas
pour que ça évolue
en tout cas pour qu'ils justice
justement vis-à-vis de ces violences
policières
monsieur chauvière veux je veux que la
presse je veux que la presse continue à
étaler notre notre notre comment notre
misère qu'on nous apporte et qu'elle
continue à croquer faire comprendre et à
croire comme a fait une libération comme
un fait médiapart qui s'investissent
pour avoir les preuves et quand on a les
preuves aujourd'hui que les étals et
comme ils l'ont fait on a eu deux super
équipe qui nous engueuler et contours
tous notés tous marqués qu'ont fait les
détails qui aurait été qu'on était
précis par rapport au rapport de l'igpn
est aujourd'hui c'est un peu grâce à eux
qu'on eut excusez moi le courage d'aller
au charbon et puis de toutes est allé
parce que maintenant aujourd'hui il ya
plus d'avocat en face il ya plus rien
tout le monde est à bas qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là c'est accablant c est
accablant parce qu'il ya tellement de
preuves il ya eu l'appel à témoins carac
a réuni qui a ramené beaucoup de monde
et aujourd'hui vous trouvez que vous
trouvez qu'on va encore pouvoir mentir
lacets qui sait quel est le premier mini
c'est comment le ministre de la justice
et qui qui va arriver à faire quelque
chose qui va pouvoir doit entériner
cette affaire on pourra plus jamais
d'entériner parce que moi je vous le dis
je me battrai jusqu'à la dernière minute
jusqu'au dernier souffle pour que la
vérité a éclaté peu pour que ces gens là
ils souhaitent condamner
ils ont toujours pas été mise à pied
vous trouvez ça normal loties la sortie
des insultes racistes
il a été mis à pied dans les 24 heures
qui suivaient et aujourd'hui on a tué un
homme qui travaillait qui est partie au
boulot on l'a tué sont toujours pas
mises à pied vous trouvez ça normal
est ce qu'on trouve ça normal
aujourd'hui merci mr ces questions merci
beaucoup cristolien d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le père est de cédric chevaux via homme
de 42 ans et qui était mort lors de
suite à son arrestation en janvier
dernier sentiment partagé au lendemain
de l'accord sur le plan de relance
européen emmanuel macron un salut est le
moment le plus important depuis la
création de l'euro mais l'accord ne se
fait pas sans sacrifices le montant des
subventions passe de 500 à 390 milliards
elle d'euros 360 autres milliards seront
disponibles sous forme de prêts
remboursables par le pays demandeur est
certains programmes européens ont été
revues à la baisse
on voit ça en images
[Musique]
des coupes budgétaires annoncées par
davide est sa soul in président du
parlement européen écouter dauphiné
libéré les chevaux jeter nous comptons
nous concentrer sur les coupes
budgétaires qui d'après nous sont
injustifiables
si nous voulons miser sur les jeunes
nous ne pouvons pas couper les
ressources budgétaires pour la recherche
la jeunesse erasmus la léchère cavani et
la mouche il faut ouvrir une négociation
pour parvenir à un cadre financier
pluriannuel plus utile à la vie des pays
mais également la vie des citoyens et il
faut pouvoir soutenir à moyen et long
terme les objectifs de l'union
mike pompé au danemark ce mercredi une
visite du chef de la diplomatie
américaine axée sur la coopération dans
l'arctique en toile de fond la guerre
commerciale avec la chine le secrétaire
d'état américain s'est entretenu avec la
première ministre est danoise avec qui
donald trump s'était brouillée l'an
passé au sujet du roi landes
aujourd'hui mais qd on paie au s'est
félicité de la réunion qui marque selon
lui un nouveau départ pour les états
unis
le web c'est un nouveau jour pour les
états unis et le guen langues
la réouverture du consulat américain à
nu réactive une présence américaine qui
était en sommeil depuis bien trop
longtemps
les etats unis ont également signé de
nouveau protocole d'accord pour coopérer
avec nos partenaires du royaume du
danemark
on couvre un large éventail de domaines
comme la croissance des secteurs minier
et énergétique du bois landes
grâce à des investissements transparent
l'aide à la gestion et à la pêche
l'augmentation du tourisme et bien
d'autres encore donald trump qui est
souhaitait on le rappelle lé dernière
htl ce territoire autonome s'est vu
opposer une fin de non recevoir
retour sur ce différend entre copenhague
et washington
avec cécilia chamond le 16 août 2019 cet
article du wall street journal lance une
information insolite
donald trump souhaiterait racheter le
groënland
ce qui passe dans un premier temps pour
un gag est vite confirmée par
l'intéressé le groenland je ne sais pas
ça a été dévoilée d'une façon ou d'une
autre c'est quelque chose dont nous
avons parlé il appartient
essentiellement au danemark
nous sommes de très bons alliés avec le
danemark nous protégeons le danemark
comme nous protégeons une grande partie
du monde
le concept donc apparu et j'ai dit
stratégiquement c'est intéressant
d'acheter nous serions intéressés mais
nous allons voir leur parler un peu
dès le départ la réponse des
groenlandais ainsi que celle du danemark
auquel ce territoire autonome est
rattachée est sans appel c'est non j'ai
déjà dit que le groenland n'est pas à
vendre et ce n'est pas un jeu de plus en
plus de personnes voient des
opportunités au groenland
mais ce que nous souhaitons ce sont des
partenaires pour le développement
commercial du groenland pour la première
ministre danoise la proposition du
président américain et je cite absurde
sanctions diplomatiques immédiate de la
maison blanche
la visite de trump au danemark prévue
les 2 et 3 septembre suivant est annulé
le danemark est un pays très spécial
avec des gens incroyables mais étant
donné les propos de la première ministre
mme été frédéric scène affirmant qu'elle
n'aurait aucun intérêt à discuter de
l'achat du groenland
je reporterais notre réunion prévue dans
deux semaines pour une autre fois
par la suite quelques appels
téléphoniques apaise les tensions entre
les deux pays
preuve d'un rapprochement en avril
dernier le gouvernement groenlandais
accepte quelque 12 millions de dollars
dead américaine pour des projets civils
puis le 10 juin avec le feu vert de
copenhague les américains rouvrent même
leur consulat au groënland 67 ans après
l'avoir fermé le groenland un bijou de
plus de 2 millions de kilomètres carrés
au coeur de l'arctique avec la fonte de
la calotte glaciaire une zone économique
exclusive de plus en plus convoité tant
sur le plan économique que stratégique
la deuxième plus grande île
monde est une porte d'entrée des routes
maritimes de l'arctique c'est aussi le
terreau d'une possible l'exploitation
offshore dans le futur son sol dont on
pourrait aussi extraire les fameuses
terres rares ces métaux utilisés par
exemple dans la fabrication de
smartphones
jusqu'à présent la chine est le
principal fournisseur de ces matériaux
la perspective d'une nouvelle
exploitation au groenland pourrait être
un atout pour les etats-unis dans la
guerre commerciale qui l'oppose à l'
empire du milieu washington semble ne
pas pouvoir se passer du royaume
scandinave allié historique fidel
on se souvient par exemple que les
danois ont participé aux guerres d'irak
et d'afghanistan
aux côtés des américains alors le voile
en est il à vendre éléments de réponse
avec douglas yates professeur de droit
et spécialiste de la politique et mec
c'était en espère un plaisanterie aussi
nord c'était ridicule d'acheter le
greenline souvent ministration 30 ne
semble pas comprendre les sentiments de
souveraineté des autres pays mais en
disant ça les etats unis auraient ouvert
au consulat trt en route ils ont
toujours une base aérienne à tulle est
donc les états unis hôte est entrée
stratégique et c'est ça que leur bêtise
de dole on trempe a indiqué que les
états unis entre le regagne de l'entrée
stratégique dans la région arctique à
cause de l'effondrement de la classe les
routes martin ouvre un et le grand monde
comme vous avez bien dit avant le
reportage est une porte d'entrée à cette
nouvelle méditerranée autre visite à
diplomatique aujourd'hui le ministre
algérien des affaires étrangères était à
moscou cet après midi à sabri a
boukadoum a discuté avec son homologue
russe sergueï lavrov des partenariats
économiques entre les deux pays
évoqué également les situations au mali
en syrie mais aussi et surtout en libye
le chef de la diplomatie russe lance un
appel au cessez le feu est à l'arrêt
immédiat de l'avancée des troupes du
gouvernement de tripoli
l'objectif final de nos efforts c'est la
restitution de l'intégrité territoriale
de la libye de la restauration de la
communauté les billets n'a été a
détruite un chan 2011 à à cause des
efforts de l'otan'' au détriment et sans
respecter les résolutions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et dans le contact
avec toutes les parties libyennes et
nous travaillons avec chacun avec
chacune de ces parties dans nos contacts
avec l iep voisin d'olivier avec elle
les acteurs extérieurs nous toujours
attirons l'attention au cessez le feu
immédiat à l'arrêt des hostilités mais
pas en tant que point final dans nos
tentatives dans nos efforts mais en tant
qu'etat qui doit être suivi
immédiatement dans le cadre du comité de
résolution de questions militaires dans
le cadre du dialogue politique
compte tenu de toutes les régions de la
libye
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité
et dans un peu plus de trente minutes
[Musique]
m
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui